yeah welcome to this video a 15-minute
game again I'm what I play last time
really forgot ok let's go in for most of
the time I have more closed openings but
let's mix it up a bit yeah so should i
play now let's play the room and see
what black like place yeah the Berlin
yeah don't really want want the long end
game but tedious so let's play d 3 so
this is some more like a standard Roy of
course black could have played instead
of d6 also could have played Bishop c5
which is some a bit more more active
these six is fine though it sound not
not a bad move at all so we went Bishop
d7 no interesting maybe one ideas Knight
a5 is this an idea try to exchange the
bishop the ad 95 looks a bit weird I
could play Bishop a form to make sure
that this Bishop isn't exchanged or just
castles of course and then but the 95
mmm I'm not sure 95 s probably not a
real real threat but I like to preserve
this Bishop so let's play Bishop a form
aha now g6 all right some that's
conducts complete development here the
question is should I class law or should
I plane i def one night have 1 2 g-3
yeah i do this first complete this
typical maneuver so that after castle
some i don't necessarily need to play
rookie 122 to complete this regrouping
yeah my dears Bishop b3 and secure the
bishop place on a tune hmm yeah Black
has some multiple ideas yeah even this
one a play Bishop b3 now should be six
I've not G far ok let's go here the
bishop is some a bit silly on a for now
anyway yeah I thought no chief I've
would be a bit a bit annoying for black
but yeah he just has Bishop g4 and it's
not clear what what I had accomplished
probably nothing
okay i'll try this anyway Bishop g4
Queen c2h6 h3 is my idea not sure if it
is any good looks rather strange to be
honest age 6 8 3 yeah I think it's
playable from a technical point of view
but not quite sure what it is really
doing it takes on g5 I take on g4 d if
you would take on g4 I can take d5 and
you can never take on e4 because of 7s
hanging so oh it can take their but okay
and so it's still playable h2x g5 HTG
for takes e4 94 probably yeah somewhat
strange some strange position yeah okay
he just retreated so there's no I'm
direct refutation fount of my idea so
but I still probably need to retreat now
and now we can return to your sex with
this Bishop if you want yeah so the
question is some is taking them
the threat or something take en don't be
three the exchange of this bishops are
not much I can do I mean this is simply
I'm nothing much for white probably this
is some round equal yeah with d3 mc3
stuff you cannot really expect them to
get some some big advantage if white
wants to play for something in the
bowlin you really needs to play this end
game but okay suddenly I'm I didn't get
so much out of be three year as I should
d3 it's not terribly dangerous but I'm
also not um yeah natural 1d4 player to
some the zone of an experienced King
pong player suddenly would have gotten a
bit more out of this just purchase
probably am no big thing as I got
nothing to get getting more than nothing
at some it some doable okay we should be
three yoga okay it's a it's a bit a bit
better than nothing simply because the
g7 bishop is am so not a great piece but
then like I certainly rather solid you
shouldn't get into any serious trouble
yeah
what should like to him he can he can
try to activate the special on g7 was
something like let's say king h7 protect
each six pawn and then trying to
activate it along f8 this is a
possibility but the visual evade term
doesn't doesn't help on its own yeah
maybe so um White has a little something
I so bleep prefer white by a small
margin he has no bad piece and the
bishop Onge is having a slight problem
yeah and black hasn't turned yet riya
deployed his bishop his knight on c6
senses a constant problem and then the
Italian game structures that the knight
on c6 is simply not well placed it does
nothing but protect the e5 pawn it's the
only duty that this night has on c6 and
it's not particularly well placed
another another function because the
poll on c3 always controls a defo mmm
and before those two squares and the
night simply has nowhere to go this
position would let's say let's remove
the knight on f3 and on c6 then this
would be a big improvement phone for
black alright so how do you improve the
position now if you're white yeah it's
not that easy it's a move like bishop a
foreign idea attacking me five
qualico they could simply take it only
six but this is really a bit yeah seem
some too accommodating maybe this should
be a form really the idea to attack now
e5 so threatening to take on c6 and then
95 and also prepare the beep on yr ok he
retreats now now before there's actually
now threatens Bishop c5 Bishop c5
Queenie six only move Bishop b3 at the
Queen strapped quite funny but you would
certainly am see this at least I hope
because it's kind of ok this kind of
sudden ends of games or so always quite
funny but in a game with um black resign
yeah in this game with them commentariat
spits it's just weird yeah like a like
losers material now Queenie six Bishop
b3 end the poor Queen is strapped yeah
of course a six wasn't term wasn't
necessary like an play a move likely to
be six and controlling this and why does
better i've got some some space
advantage end and all around ammonia's
position but black still is fairly solid
note that really the night see a problem
I mean this is not a logistics is just
just not a good piece it's very often an
idea to redeploy this and also question
is if you look at this kind of position
um what like some best setup is here one
idea is simply to to take on e4 take on
b3
change this off let's say here this kind
of stuff or the Queen e7 first years
also possible let's sit here and then
this kind of idea ideas to play a queen
to you 6 and this should should be
pretty equal let's say here and I think
now queen e6 you you can consider can
you take mmm not sure if white cannot
take then this is an immediate equalizer
as this kind of stuff yeah yeah okay
white white has maybe a bit but it's
it's very very little I can try to
activate hear this click on the default
see the lightest bit of problem this is
somewhat stupid piece as it's only
function is to cover a five and it can
always be pushed so I have this kind of
positions of course sometimes it's black
also from the Italian gamut this is also
always the thing that I try to do to
prove this knight on c6 and when this
kind of position is probably very
slightly better for white but it's it's
it's not much at all and yeah and then
the gamey sort of game to wait some some
territory step by step and here this
before is really I think Bishop d7 is
maybe too too passive maybe they're
there are other moves not shown this one
how to tell but yeah this is what we got
in the game this is this is already
slightly annoying i mean b6 it's not a
movie or yo you absolutely want to play
and now i can just play here let's play
another one and maybe queen bee three
and maybe ship will be three back end
yeah it's a bit it's a bit a bit of an
advantage
it's not super terrible for black but
it's not nice to play yeah thanks for
watching